hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to let's play vanish okay this
is a horror game that is an early alpha
so please don't mind any bugs that you
may see what you were playing into while
you watching me play bla bla bla normal
disclaimer let's get into it
this seems to be a sort of dungeon
crawly
wandering around in a sort of abandoned
place which is kind of a typical theme
that you see in a lot of horror games
but you will notice that it actually
looks pretty good got my volume turned
up pretty loud which is weird because
everything seems to be quiet okay I'm in
some sort of a vault wondering if
there's part of this SCP foundation well
yeah it does look like a lot of work has
been put into it and I have no idea what
to expect other than that I can see that
this is gonna be a problematic because
even though this light is very bright
now I could barely frickin see it in the
dark
hello why am I here the eternal burning
question that lies in every game that I
play why am I here okay I must say that
right off the atmosphere and premise are
both very good but also very familiar
because it kind of reminds me of playing
one of the SCP will hello Phil if you
see this my radios busted heading back
to the access ladder to grab a
replacement alrighty then who's Phil and
Hank
am i Phil is he Hank I don't know okay
so we seem to be in the sewers but for
what purpose
I do not know other than that there seem
to be a lot of leaks slightly
claustrophobic in here dark creepy
hallways and such alright okay anyway
balls to the wall
let's just keep plowing forward um that
light out I probably don't want to go
the way the lights are out
but I will go anyway oh hello arrow well
I guess I might be headed in the right -
wait does that arrow pointing down err
just tell me this way aha here we go
sure smells down here I'm taking a lot
more turns to get to the jhen room than
I remember
okay Hank Hank is that you buddy
Hank Hank why are you asking me Hank
Hank I'm very disturbed right now okay
so are we going in a circle wait I see a
little tiny dot of light dad's probably
nothing Raj is a graphical thing
clipping surfaces and all that I really
never heard of the company that made
this game is called three drunk
gentlemen or drunk man here's another
light out okay what's on okay all right
just done nothing bothering me here
nothing to be worried about just this
ramshackle old thingy that clanks and
doesn't move open all right everybody
calm down there is no need to panic we
have the situation under control in your
cooperation
okay damn it at the ladder but forgot
the keys to the access gate and I'm on
my last glow stick there's no way I'll
be able to find them without extra light
Hank
follow the pipes I could have sworn that
I made enough turns to make a circle
back to where I was before
oh ah no thank you I don't want any
please go away
guy forever in a fire fall down a
mountain of hell and fall into a pit of
death fall down a mountain into a pit of
death that's what I'm saying I'm
following the pipes but the pipe seemed
to be pretty monotonous allies both
oh hello do I wanna well III don't wanna
but the teams I gotta cuz where the hell
did this wall come from I don't like
this I like it want to pick out keeping
oh I shouldn't have turned the volume so
high but it helps build the atmosphere
when you play these guys when you play
these games guys and gals ladies when
you play these games
always remember to crank the volume up
way high so there's a melody it's a
thingy
ah oh crap hey hey what is it
lose it lose it huh oh oh look it's no
no no no no now stop being so creepy
you're supposed to chase me and yell at
me no just walk creepily fat what the
hell are you hi ha
yeah my brother knew about oh you're so
weird
hi buddies you have no face or you have
a face but it's kind of app off and
really disturbing you got a bird like
this base Adam lemon butter does dumb
idea those dumb you died and I'm being
laid dragged to a pit to be eaten alive
okay that was dumb don't run straight
into the monster don't try to run past
the monster
it leads I don't know if this place is
randomly generated or what but it kind
of felt that way considering it's all
the same sort of hallways and I could
have sworn that I was gonna make a
circle back to where I was before but
uh-oh can't go that way
oh that was me breathing oh sure what
that was okay so the general gist of
what I'm trying to say is that I'm
slitting a sluzzle slow booty with all
of the Ilia little of it am I making
sense here are you understanding when
I'm putting are you picking up what I'm
putting down is that what I'm trying to
say I don't know all I know is that this
definitely seems to be randomly
generated and he's just about as creepy
and since if bo8 seven the one made by
the same guy that made containment
breach did I go this way I can't
remember since they're all different I
goes into the matter just got to watch
out for the thing donkeys don't want to
be messing with no thing donkeys okay I
think I went straight I'll go left
I've lost all my pages Slenderman will
be very upset or whatever the hell that
mom [ __ ] what it was so creepy it just
it didn't change me in pursues it's kind
of like no Dan what are you doing over
here mmm you look tasty
oh wait I'm done
on the runway cash warned huh do the
sworn I was going the right way or maybe
the arrows are a lie and they just lead
me right into the monsters so that they
can devour my bones the power my bones
in the little pieces oh my god run
goodbye me about any comic there all
right picking it up go go go go that was
a painted on arrow not one of the white
this is a good I got shot okay all right
okay yes
aha you're the white arrows are a trap
I'm not safe here am i it's got a gun a
okay
okie-dokie alrighty then
well this game has reached a whole new
level level of douche Oh super mega
ultra douche wait a minute there's a
door there I want to go to there I want
to go home oh no but it is by me you
know get it know in get in the home
actual chief [ __ ] [ __ ] in the hallway
down there but I don't want to find out
oh oh oh look at a WDM a somebody
everybody oh I'm so boned
I'm Bonin oh I'm beyond boned I'm super
ultra mega boned
please run faster thank you Dawg you the
hall with the dev hole you know get out
uh-huh okay screw that hallway what the
hell Bobby what AK well i'ma hit
so some that caused my vision to perturb
you late and turn into super douche miss
yes game as good I was gonna say bad but
it's actually good okay huh
fellow donno what happened it snuck up
on me I knew I was gonna die so I just
stood there I don't think you could see
me stay safe tank okay so they're kind
of blind which would make sense
considering were underground so they're
the mole people had the mole person
it didn't see me it didn't see me it
didn't see me it only heard me okay so
that's my first and last line of defense
what's with what I there was another
arrow that pointed that way but I wanted
to go to there but I don't want to touch
him wait a minute what's all this in a
final jump Hank Hank Hank
Hank
you.your hang thankee thankee
so no ah oh okay
oh no give it oh oh no you don't see a
bloody thing
you don't see a bleeding bloody thing
that's right walk away bastard I barely
walk
yeah well I'll be baby this game Cara hi
legit yeah this game is good love it
love randomly generated horror games are
the best cuz it's a new experience every
time you play that's good
what made SCP containment breach so
successful same with it always happen
because every floor was random I mean it
was only a set pattern but think of it
they've created like a larger set of
rooms to copy off of as you're going
down it would have been even more
dastardly I mean it was pretty bad the
first time I played it but there's
pretty darn good and plus the fact that
it looked good excuse me was another
thing entirely sorry Snape before it
sits so thank you everybody for watching
hope you want to play the game for
yourself because the link in the
description below
you should definitely definitely try it
for yourself so thank you everybody so
much for watching click the innovation
to war videos I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
Oh
this is some science Hospital
ah
oh they're catering
thank you
ah
sucks the life out of that patient or
something
what is going on